yeah hello welcome to this video i'll be
doing after a long game started long
pause and some five-minute games again
and I'll changed a bit of setup here ok
the move animation is some a bit slow
but that chant changed also the on the
bottom hope you like it i think it's
quite quite attractive looking all right
we got some pretty weird opening here
some yeah combination of a chicken and
the Albin's but without the night some
actually add this in a tournament game
on some years ago and i think it's
pretty good for white but as usual in
these kind of positions things are not
so so clear-cut ok i'm trying to attack
the Seaforth on i'm not quite sure if i
should protect it really how I should
protect it I could go Quincy to then you
might play Queen a five and capture you
five it's not a big deal really yeah I
think I'll I just ignore this is not
really well developed grabs it anyway
alright so what I'm doing now just be
three Bishop b2 getting trying to get it
back yeah try that don't want to get to
a long time
yeah we can go to e6 now on the other
diagonal okay of course he's got d3 now
which might be an issue come c 5 yeah
I'd like to play you three you open it
opening the position up even more but of
course this Bishop perm is somewhat
annoying and also you could do maybe
just take ok let's try to develop the
rest of the pieces it's not like I'm a
huge problem I'm not even upon down here
at one point after all ok not sure how
to cut to continue maybe just rook e1
and e3
this Bishop is just biting at this porno
deform and not doing much this is why I
want to play you three really
okay the son surprises me a bit that you
simply opens up the position here I was
more expecting move like d3
now one idea is 94 to do six which would
be very annoying so I guess Rock d 8
it's the move from that you will play
now or maybe 95 gaining a temple or long
long castle
yeah maybe it's got ideas like 95 to be
formed possible
maybe I should give this check on g4
check he goes 27 I could exchange I
think I'm favor favorably for me so and
now right here a 95 i can go rook to e3
yeah and still I have this 96 idea
okay yeah Quinn to you for maybe looks
like a good diagonal okay so what about
e6 now e six takes 95 that's an idea
okay don't want to spend too much time
look looks active at least it takes
Bishop takes bishop d6 yeah okay it
doesn't take so just this night threaten
anything or kind of played before before
to open the position maybe neither five
it's an idea then I would have rook a3
threatening okay 60 okay if you take
that can take the form okay three is a
cool idea threatening to check let's
check it quickly yeah ok 6 pa6 Queen
Queen a a checkmate
all right okay prevented this still it
looks some very dangerous okay oops ok
I'll sec the exchange now opening up the
position warm-time morning what about 92
g 6 maybe 96 and Queen takes e6 really
lots lots of pieces hanging maybe I
could have played this even without the
the exchange sec have next position is
some very shaky but it's of course some
pretty messy position so easy to to
wrongly evaluate this not quite sure
what you should do now rookies hanging
rope g6 Queen takes e6 every piece is
hanging both bishops just fantastic
resides oh it just resigned yeah maybe
there is no move hard to see what your
tea should do turn on the computer
quickly yeah it's plus 5 there is no
movie yeah this was a very risky opening
choice all right yeah thanks for
watching um and also welcome any
feedback on the new board and and
everything if you like it it's very very
nice I think um the only thing I just so
I don't have any coordinates at the
board I'm not sure if you would prefer
to have
have some yeah okay leave me any
feedback on this thanks